vous savez maintenant noël et moi c'est
une longue histoire
c'est pour moi non qu'est ce que c'est
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est un gars doux
ses surprises c'est ça qu'est ce que
c'était un hamster à chaque fois qu'on
s'approche des fêtes je pense à noël
quand j'étais gamin parce que j'étais
euphorique
j'étais comme un dingue quelques
semaines avant noël pour moi c'était
impossible de ne pas chercher les
cadeaux partout dans la maison
alors je sais c'est débile un jeu me
spoil et tout comme un con et le pire
c'est que je devais jouer la surprise
quand je déballais mes cadeaux du court
waouh des rollers merci maman c'est le
cadeau de mamie est en train d'ouvrir la
wii ça veut dire que j'ai deviné ton
cadeau
j'ai super pouvoirs en parlant de
cadeaux quand j'étais gamin je pouvais
clairement identifié deux types de noël
bien distincts d'abord le noël où je
recevais une console et puis il y avait
les autres noël à des crayons de couleur
[Musique]
merci papa merci maman alors je vais pas
me plaindre c'est bien des crayons de
couleur il ya des enfants dans le monde
qui ont bien que ça pour noël donc je me
plains pas par contre je dirais pas mon
cadeau à mes potes à l'école moi j'ai eu
une voiture téléguidée qui se transforme
quand elles roulent plus que sympa et
toi j'ai eu des crayons de couleur
laser d'écran couleur laser qui envoient
des trucs sur les murs et au tu vas fait
peur d'accord tu la ramènes non c'est
mon cadeau
or je sais pas comment ça se passe dans
les autres familles mais moi mes parents
ils sont plutôt nul en noël on ouvrait
les cadeaux le soir et mes parents
avaient une technique carrément chelou
pour mettre les cadeaux au pied du sapin
sans qu'on le voit il me demandait
cyprien va ranger ta chambre
oui le soir de noël
grosse grosse ambiance bah du coup je me
ranger ma chambre et quand je revenais
haute a loupé le père noël il a déposé
les cadeaux bon le problème avec cette
technique
en plus d'être totalement nul à chier
c'est que ça marche une fois cyprien va
ranger déjà rangé ma chambre
est-ce que tu as passé l'aspirateur j'ai
repris mes vêtements j'ai resserré lit
j'ai refait la peinture l'électricité le
chauffage au sol l'isolation j'ai coulé
une dalle et j'ai pété un mur pour
agrandir ah bah mince pendant que tu
parlais le père noël il a déposé les
cadeaux merde je me rappelle très bien
du moment où j'ai arrêté de croire au
père noël
c'était justement un soir de noël
c'était mon oncle qui s'était déguisé en
père noël
alors il était plutôt bien déguisé là
n'est pas le problème le problème c'est
qu'il est resté déguisé toute la soirée
elle s'y prête je pose la bouteille la
bouteille
sinon ça va à l'école il pas un peu
quand ton fils est d'ailleurs le noël
dernier j'ai pu me déguiser en père noël
c'est pas une blague
c'était mon voisin qui m'avait demandé
de me déguiser pour ses enfants comme il
m'avait jamais vu va du coup il s'est tu
es obligé de croire que le père noël
existe et enzo voilà le père noël s'est
encore tonton déguisé en père noël
j'ai peut-être pris un peu trop goût et
ouais tu pensais que c'était ton oncle
et je sais qui le père noël un plus
jamais tu crois plus au moins tentant
oui oui oui le père noël oui le père
noël et ben voilà c'est pas c'est dur tu
veux faire gros que tu vas faire face au
père noël je peux voler dans un traîneau
mes amis ce sont des [ __ ] de lutins
père noël si je veux les cadeaux à noël
mon gars brillant au sipri c'est le
prénom du voisin ça il ya un truc qui me
manque un truc qui n'existe plus un truc
quand je le voyais je savais que c'était
bientôt noël c'était cette pub chez moi
le père noël tous les enfants peuvent
téléphoner
écoutez bien mon numéro 65
c'est un enfant veut rater croire au
père noël de manière immédiate faut
qu'ils appellent ce numéro parce que le
service existe encore et c'est la plus
grosse arnaque de la planète
j'ai tué quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
adolf hitler dans ton cul connard bon
j'avoue préférer noël quand j'étais plus
jeune un avant noël c'était beau des
cadeaux bon et maintenant c'est plus la
bouffe
la boucle est encore un parce que le
sort de noël sur la table les parents il
ya toujours deux trucs qui sont toujours
là
le foie gras ça ça va jusqu'à ce que ma
soeur interviennent tu as vu cette vidéo
sur le gavage des canards et mon père
raffole des huîtres il y en a tous les
ans et ça je ne peux pas je suis désolé
dans ma tête
les huîtres sont fait comme ça
et bien jaune
merci suivante oui et comme c'est
bientôt noël et que vous avez été sages
j'ai un petit cadeau j'ai créé pour vous
le site je me fais chier point fr c'est
pour quand vous vous faites chier vous
indiquer le temps que vous avez à faire
sur le site et ça vous créer une
playlist aléatoire de mes vidéos et
surtout est la fin des vidéos vous aurez
droit à des anecdotes inédites comme par
exemple des bêtisiers j'ai envie de
faire un temps pour tout et rien ou des
scènes coupées et des trucs que je
déteste changer de couleur d'un stylo
quatre couleurs ah [ __ ] et me le
prendre dans la dent allez-y c'est mon
cadeau de noël je me fais chier point fr
je me bats je me bats je sais pas écrire
un vrai show